five years ago i started my work on a
cart and was selling
snacks very worried about the continuous
increase of prices as all my livelihood
depends on edible oil and gas and the
prices of both has increased and now out
of reach
we used to buy oil at 120 rupees per
kilo during the nawaz sharif government
and during the government of imran khan
prices have gone up tremendously if you
do the comparison with today's prices
it's 300 percent more
the poor can't even afford a piece of
bread these days may allah save this
country as by the looks we are about to
go bankrupt look at the dollar rate look
at the price of oil and ghee it's on the
rise every day
both government the previous and present
are unable to control the price hike
the price of petrol has been increased
by 30 rupees per liter in the last week
and now we're hearing that it's going to
go up to one dollar per liter which will
make our lives worsen
everything is so expensive and i'm
worried how to bear the expenses i am
paying 150 us dollars rent for the house
and 130 us dollars for my tuck shop and
it's hard to earn even that
we are three people working at this shop
and can't even earn the basic expenses
i can't even dream to buy something good
for my children i brought them to work
with me to minimize the expenses so that
i shouldn't close my businesses to have
a piece of bread at least
i wish and pray if any government comes
if they should look for the benefits of
poor like us and should control
inflation